as we returned home from Mass we would
often meet Monsieur the calm down who
was detained in Paris by his profession
of engineer and except during the summer
vacations could come to his property
income kaya only from Saturday evening
until Monday morning he was one of those
men who quite apart from a career in
science in which they have in fact been
brilliantly successful possess an
entirely different culture one that is
literary artistic which their
professional specialization does not
make use of and which enrich is their
conversation it's better read than many
men of letters we did not know at the
time that Monsieur calm down had a
certain reputation as a writer and we
were very surprised to see that a famous
musician had composed a melody to some
verses of his gifted with more facility
than many painters they imagined that
the life they are leading is not the one
that really suits them and they bring to
their actual occupations either an
indifference mingled with whimsy or an
application that is sustained and
haughty scornful bitter and
conscientious tall with a handsome
figure a fine thoughtful face with the
long blond mustache and disenchanted
blue eyes exquisitely courteous a
conversationalist such as we had never
heard before he was in the eyes of my
family who always cited him as an
example the epitome of the superior man
approaching life in the noblest and most
delicate way my grandmother approached
him only for speaking a little too well
a little too much like a book for not
having the same naturalness in his
language as in his loosely knotted
Livadia bow ties in his short straight
almost school boyish coat she was
surprised by the fiery tirades he often
launched against the aristocracy against
fashionable life against snobbery which
he called certainly the sin which Saint
Paul has in mind when he speaks of the
sand for which there is no forgiveness
worldly ambition was a sentiment that my
grandmother was so incapable of feeling
or even almost of understanding that it
seemed to her quite pointless to bring
so much harder to stigmatizing it what
was more she did not
get in very good taste that Monsieur
dançando whose sister near Baalbek was
married to a titled gentleman of lower
normandy should indulge himself in such
violent attacks against the nobility
going so far as to reproach the
revolution for not having had them all
guillotine greetings my friends he would
say coming up to us how fortunate you
are to live here for such extended
periods of time tomorrow I must return
to Paris to my little nook oh he would
add with his own particular smile gently
ironical disappointed and slightly
distracted of course my house contains
every useless thing in the world it
lacks only the one essential a large
piece of sky like this one always try to
keep a piece of sky over your life
little boy he would add turning to me
you have a lovely soul of a rare quality
and artists nature don't ever let it go
without what it needs when we returned
home and my aunt sent to us to ask if
Madame goo peel had been late coming to
mass we could not give her any
information instead we increased her
disturbance by telling her there was a
painter at work in the church copying
the window of Gilbert the bad house was
sent immediately to the grocery came
back empty-handed owing to the absence
of Toyota whose two professions that of
chorister with a part in the maintenance
of the church and of grocers boy gave
him connections in all worlds and
therefore knowledge that was universal
ah side side my hand I wish it were time
for you lady she's really the only one
who will be able to tell me who that II
was an active old maid lame and hard of
hearing who had retired after the death
of Madame de la puerta and avi with whom
she had been in service since her
childhood and had then taken a room next
to the church descending from it
constantly either for the services or
when there was no service to say a
little prayer or give teodoro hand the
rest of the time she visited invalids
like my hat Leone to whom she would
describe what happened at mass or advice
furs she was not above adding some
revenue to the small pension paid her by
the family of her former employers by
going from time to time to look at
to the QA his linen without of some
other prominent personality in quantized
clerical world above a cloak of black
cloths she wore a small white hood
almost like a nun's and a skin disease
gave parts of her cheeks and her hooked
nose the bright pink tones of an
impatience her visits were the great
diversion of my hat Leonie who hardly
received anyone else now apart from mr.
lecoeur hi my aunt had gradually
eliminated all the other visitors
because all of them made the mistake in
her eyes of belonging to one of two
categories of people whom she detested
one group the worst whom she got rid of
first were the ones who advised her not
to listen to herself so and subscribed
if only negatively manifesting it only
by certain disapproving silences or by
certain dubious miles to the subversive
doctrine the little walk in the Sun and
a good rare beef steak even though two
wretched sips of Vichy water would lie
on her stomach for 14 hours would do her
more good than her bed and her medicines
the other category was made up of the
people who seemed to believe she was
more seriously ill than she herself
thought that she was a seriously ill as
she said she was and so those who though
she had allowed to come up after some
hesitation and upon cos was kindly meant
in treaties and who in the course of her
Villa of their visit had shown how very
unworthy they were of the favor being
done to them by timidly risking a don't
you think that if you were to move about
a little when the weather's fine or who
on the contrary when she said to them
I'm very low very low this is the end my
poor friends answered her ah when our
health fails us still you may last a
while longer yet as you are these the
former as well as the latter were
certain never to be received again and
if house was was abused by my aunt's
horrified look when from her bed she saw
one of those people in the Hoosier sent
is pre apparently coming toward her
house or when she heard the doorbell
rang she would laugh more heartily still
as though it a good trick at my aunt's
ever victorious ruses for managing to
have them turn to
I at their discomforted expression as
they went off without having seen her
and at heart admired her mistress whom
she felt to be superior to all these
people since she did not want to receive
them in short might have required that
her visitors at the same time commend
her on her regimen commiserate her with
her for her sufferings and encourage her
as to the future this was where you that
he excelled my ad might say to her 20
times in a minute this is the end my
poor your the 20 times or that he would
answer knowing your illness as you know
it madam octa you will live to be a
hundred as madam size of ha was saying
to me just yesterday one of the ladies
firmest beliefs which the impressive
number of denials contributed by
experience had not been enough to shake
was that madam Sasuke's name was madam
so calm I am NOT asking to live to a
hundred answered my hat who preferred
not to see her days assigned a precise
term and since along with this without a
new better than anyone else had to
distract my aunt without tiring her her
visits which took place regularly every
Sunday barring an unforeseen obstacle
were for my aunt a pleasure the prospect
of which kept her on those days in a
state that was at first pleasant but
quite soon painful like an excessive
hunger if Elodie was even a little late
/ overly prolonged this ecstasy of
waiting for who they became a torment my
aunt booked constantly at the time
beyond felt faint the sound of the
ladies chime if it came at the very end
of the day when she was no longer
expecting it would make her almost ill
sorry would make would almost make her
hill the fact that on Sunday the fact
was that on Sunday she thought only of
this visit and as soon as lunch was
finished kosmos would be in a hurry for
us to leave the dining room so that she
could go up and occupy my aunt but
especially once the fine weather settled
in at quan chi a good long time would go
by after the haughty hour of noon
descending from the Santee lock steeple
which it had emblazoned with the twelve
momentary rosettes of its owner as Crown
had echoed around our table close to the
consecrated bread which had also come in
familiar
after church while we remain seated
sitting in front of the Thousand and One
Nights plates oppressed by the heat and
especially by the meal for a pound upon
a permanent upon a permanent foundation
of eggs cutlets potatoes jams biscuits
which he no longer even announced to us
pastas would add depending on the
laborers in the fields and orchards the
fruit of the tide the luck of the
marketplace the kindness of neighbors
and her own genius and with the result
that our menu like the Quattro foils
carved on the portal of cathedrals in
the 13th century reflected somewhat the
rhythm of the seasons and the incidence
of daily life a brill because the monger
had guaranteed her that it was fresh a
turkey hen because she had seen a large
one at the hoose avila pound market
cartoons with marrow because she had not
made them for us that way before a roast
leg of mutton because fresh air whets
the appetite and it would have plenty of
time to descend in the next seven hours
spinach for a change apricots because
they were still uncommon gooseberries
because in two weeks there would not be
any more raspberries that Monsieur Swann
had brought especially cherries the
first that had come from the cherry tree
in the garden after two years and in
which it had not given any cream cheese
which I like very much at one time an
almond cake because she had ordered it
the day before ugly ash because it was
our time to present it when all of that
was finished there came a work of art
composed expressly for us but more
particularly dedicated to my father who
was so fond of it a chocolate custard
the product of Colossus personal
inspiration and attention ephemeral and
light as an occasional piece into which
he had put all her talent if anyone had
refused to taste it saying I'm finished
I'm not hungry anymore that person would
immediately have been relegated to the
rank of those barbarians who even in a
gift and artist makes them of one of his
works scrutinize its weight and its
material when the only things of value
in it or its intention and its signature
to leave even a single drop of it on the
plate
would have been to display the same
impoliteness as to stand up before the
end of a piece under the very nose of
the composer